obviously this was not made
for some crazy amount of money um so i'm
curious what
how did sort of the script and story get
finessed uh with the amount of money and
resources you had to tell the story
well first off uh uh ed and
chris and keanu and alex believed
that they should there was another story
and they all uh worked on spec i mean
you know um
he wrote this ed and chris wrote it on
their own they didn't even own the
franchise then they they they wrote it
hoping they could make it
um that was 12 years ago um i was on it
for
seven years um and we kept going to
studio and then
uh it falling apart and then something
else would happen and fall apart
so it's kind of a miracle that got made
i think
uh if you look at the movie business
especially now the theatrical movie
business
you know it's hard to get a comedy made
theatrically
um they worry that it doesn't translate
overseas but um strangely enough they're
discovering that
the intent does translate um so
um but um you know it's somebody had to
believe it
and uh and and finally um uh
scott cruff who was who produced the
originals
uh and ed and and all of us were this
sort of group
trying to get this thing going and and
scott found uh
the final uh uh
investors that put this together um but
you know we had just a little bit above
zero to make it
um and uh it's hard to make a movie
um it takes place in the past the future
um hell and the destruction of all space
and time
uh as an independent low budget um
so um uh the thing that actually helped
us was
the good will um that came at us for
this movie
um i asked people who i'd worked with
who who make ten times what uh we could
pay them
if they would do it and everybody showed
up so um
there is a lot of great goodwill and
huge favors
um uh done for us and it's um
that's that's what allowed it to happen
you can see that love on screen
you know i i mean they love the
characters and also there's so much
goodwill
you know alex and keanu are also
filmmakers you know they've also both
directed produced on everything um so
between all of us uh over the last 30
years
making movies um we were able to uh put
together a pretty good
group of people actually a phenomenal
group of people given what we were doing
what we were paying sure uh what did you
end up filming on the very first day and
did you do something easy on purpose
yeah i mean most of us do that um
we want to do something easy so we can
make our schedules so we can
ease our way into it in case it doesn't
work we can redo it
but we couldn't really do that on this
movie because we only had uh
37 days so we uh we just launched into
the uh
i believe if i'm hopefully remembering
this correctly i believe it was the uh
the scenes uh in couples therapy
yeah that's that's a good way to start
simple it's in a room right although
it's it's actually
um a ridiculous scene
but but uh
yeah i mean look keanu and alex just are
incredibly gifted uh talented actors and
were
they just they were they they worked
really hard um
just rehearsing every last moment of
these things so
they came so prepared that it made it so
much easier to also
open it up if you wanted to to things
that would happen
uh out of sort of uh
to let it you know to let that last take
go where everybody just
uh can can add things that they thought
might work
um so uh it was the actual shooting of
it was difficult because it was very hot
and we're in new orleans we had no money
but it was also quite
fun and uh incredibly
i thought um focused and
efficient so um i was it's good one of
the best experiences i've had making a
movie i have to say
how long was your first cut compared to
the finished film
it was always uh short i mean i
uh i think barry seinfeld also said this
but uh
that comedy should be short um uh
i think we were all maybe five minutes
longer
okay than it is now so not much
was it um did you end up losing any
scenes or was it just pulling out some
stuff
from the scenes you'd already done it
was condensing it's what
happens naturally in an edit which is uh
at first you're in love with all your
material and your indulgence as hell and
then you start going what am i doing
that's sitting there forever um that's
not worth it let's pull this be a beat
out let's
cadet so in the process it was mostly
pacing and rearranging we we kind of
changed
changed it structurally because it hops
around
um and uh we did because we did the
second half of it in covin
um we were going to reshoot two scenes
with
uh their daughters and um
a coda ending we were going to add to it
and i have to say the result
of of the pandemic made us think outside
the box and made a better ending
um and our solutions were much more
creative as a result
of not being able to do what we could
normally do
which was a surprise i think to all of
us it's like
well this is way better than we thought
uh sodenberg talked about how um
i guess he was involved somehow in
helping to get the movie made he was
yeah we put
he came on as executive producer which
was which was a big help
sure can you talk a little bit about um
what he did to help get the movie made
well you know when you're trying to put
together a collection
of people to convince people that you
should
make a movie you're putting together
people with uh
resumes right because you're trying to
mitigate risk and so we put together a
collection of actors
directors and producers uh and and
talent
in general uh to try and sell the movie
and stephen came on early on because
we knew having stephen uh with us it
gave it sort of
um street cred um but also stephen is so
kind uh you know ed has been working
with stephen for many years
i've worked i've known ed since the 90s
and worked with him for years i know
stephen for years as well
he actually was my first screening of
galaxy quest stephen was in
that screening and giving me notes so
uh he was he was incredibly helpful when
exactly when we needed him
which was to push it uh you know forward
at those moments where people are
doubting it or
or you know he was kind of i gotta say
kind of brilliant at it
um and also would put his two cents in
every now and again which was always
here's this funny thing where it goes
it's not working or it's not working
and you go it's working so keep working
on it